el equipo de 14 expertos internacionales
continúa hoy con su trabajo de campo en
luján a donde ha llegado para intentar
averiguar el origen de la pandemia que
se ha cobrado más de 2 millones de
muertos en todo el mundo hoy han
visitado el hospital de jing jing tan
adonde llegaron algunos de los primeros
infectados desde el cercano mercado de
juanan ayer se reunieron con
funcionarios locales y visitaron otro
hospital el de xinhua donde trabajaba la
doctora que alertó por primera vez de
una neumonía de origen desconocido y que
hoy es glosada como heroína nacional no
se conocen los detalles del resto de
calendario pero la organización mundial
de la salud ha informado de que podrán
visitar lugares a los que no habían
tenido acceso en los dos viajes
anteriores como hospitales mercados o
incluso el laboratorio de máxima
seguridad al que trump había acosado sin
pruebas y en contra de la opinión de la
clase científica internacional de ser la
cuna del virus la llegada a la casa
blanca de joe biden que esta semana
prohibía que se siguiera vinculando el
virus con china para acabar con el
racismo ha relajado el ambiente y es
probable que eso vaya a facilitar el
trabajo de la misión científica estos
días en luján